CHILLING THING TO THINK ABOUT
WITH THIS BEING THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WITH NUCLEAR
CODE UNTIL JANUARY 20th.
>> YOU SAT WITH THE INTERVIEW, I
WANT TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT PART
WHEN YOU ASKED ABOUT THE JANUARY
6th INSURRECTION.
LET'S PLAY THAT.
>> WHAT DID YOU --
>> YOU KNOW THAT WASN'T MY
RALLY, THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT SPOKE, THEY HAD
RALLIES THE NIGHT BEFORE, THEY
HAD SPEAKERS ALL OVER THE CITY.
YOU HAD HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY I THINK
IT WAS THE LARGEST CROWD I EVER
SPOKE BEFORE.
IT WENT FROM THAT POINT WHICH
WAS ALMOST AT THE WHITE HOUSE TO
BEYOND THE WASHINGTON MONUMENT.
IT WAS -- AND WIDE.
AND --
>> BUT IF YOU --
>> -- AND IT WAS A LOVING CROWD
TOO, BY THE WAY, I HEARD THAT
FROM MANY, MANY PEOPLE, THAT WAS
A LOVING CROWD.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS TOO BAD.
IT WAS TOO BAD THAT THEY --
[ OVERLAPPING SPEAKERS ]
--
>> BUT MR. PRESIDENT, I
APOLOGIZE, WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS, NOT BLAME.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
>> WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
DID YOU WANT WHEN YOU SAID GO UP
THERE?
>> I WOULD HAVE SAID THAT YOU
WILL SHOW NOT TO GO IN, ALTHOUGH
THEY WERE USHERED IN BY THE
POLICE, I MEAN, IN ALL FAIRNESS,
THE CAPITOL POLICE WERE USHERING
PEOPLE IN.
THE CAPITOL POLICE WERE VERY
FRIENDLY, HUGGING AND KI -- YOU
DON'T SEE THAT BUT THERE'S
PLENTY OF TAPE ON THAT TOO, THE
CAPITOL POLICE, THAT'S THE WAY
IT IS.
I WANTED -- PERSONALLY, WHAT I
WANTED IS WHAT THEY WANTED.
THEY SHOWED UP.
JUST TO SHOW SUPPORT.
BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS RIGGED.
AT A LEVEL LIKE NOTHING HAS EVER
BEEN RIGGED BEFORE.
THERE'S TREMENDOUS PROOF.
STATISTICALLY IT WASN'T EVEN
POSSIBLE THAT HE WON.
I MEAN, THINGS SUCH AS
IN OHIO, IOWA, THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A LOSS.
>> DID YOU NEED BETTER LAWYERS
BECAUSE THEY TOOK IT TO COURT.
>> I NEEDED BETTER JUDGES.
THE SUPREME COURT WAS AFRAID TO
TAKE IT. DON'T FORGET, IF YOU
TAKE ALL OF THE -- EVERYTHING
OUT, TAKE ALL OF THE DEAD PEOPLE
THAT VOTED, AND THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF THEM, BY THE WAY,
WE HAVE LIST OF THEM,
OBITUARIES, IF YOU TAKE THE
ILLEGAL IMFRANTS THAT VOTED --
IMMIGRANTS, INDUSTRY YANZ
GETTING PAID
INDIANS GETTING PAID TO VOTE.
MANY, MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT WAS VERY, VERY CLOSE.
IT'S ONLY IN FIVE PLACES, IF YOU
TAKE ALL OF THAT, IT'S MASSIVE
NUMBERS.
FORGET ALL OF THAT. IF YOU TAKE
ALL OF THAT, JUST LOOK AT ONE
THING, THE LEGISLATURES OF THE
STATES.
DID NOT APPROVE
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WERE DONE
FOR THOSE ELECTIONS.
AND UNDER THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES THEY HAVE TO
DO THAT.
AND THE SUPREME COURT, THEY
DIDN'T FIND FACT.
DON'T FORGET, THEY DIDN'T SAY,
WELL, WE DISAGREE.
THEY SAID, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HEAR THE CASE.
I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY WERE
AFRAID OF?
>> I GUESS THEY THOUGHT THAT IT
WOULD BE VIOLENT, MAYBE.
AND IT WAS VIOLENT THE OTHER WAY
PERHAPS, I DON'T KNOW.
I GUESS THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
VIOLENT.
BUT THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN THE
CONSTITUTION, IT SAYS YOU CAN'T
HAVE LOCAL POLITICIANS SETTING
THE RULES.
AND THEY SET THE RULES.
EARLY VOTING.
THIS VOTING.
BALLOTS.
MANY, MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND THESE WERE DEMOCRATS GOING
TO REPUBLICAN -- WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF NEVADA WHICH WAS A
DEMOCRAT-LEGISLATURE, BY THE
WAY, THEY DIDN'T EVEN -- THEY
DID FOR THE MOST PART PROOF --
BUT THEY HAD THINGS THEY DIDN'T
APPROVE, BUT THE OTHER ONES HAD
VERY LITTLE, DON, ALMOST
NOTHING.
SO THEY WERE SETTING ILLEGALLY
ALL OF THESE RULES, REGULATIONS,
EVERYTHING.
POLL-WATCHERS WHO WERE
ABSOLUTELY BRUTALIZED AND THROWN
OUT.
WE HAD NO POLL WATCHERS ALLOWED
IN BUILDINGS FOR DAYS.
OKAY.
IT WAS AN ILLEGAL CORRUPT
ELECTION AS BAD AS A THIRD-WORLD
COUNTRY.
OKAY.
SO WITH THAT, THE JUDGES JUST
WOULD NOT -- THEY WOULD NOT --
>> ONE MORE BEAT ON THAT. IF YOU
HAD BAD JUDGES THAT'S LIKE 86
BAD JUDGES, SOME OF THEM WERE
PEOPLE YOU APPOINTED.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I'M NOT SAYING -- I APPOINTED
THEM AND I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN THEM.
>> I MEAN.
THERE'S SO MANY -- IT'S
FASCINATING THAT -- I SAID THIS
IS LIKE LISTENING TO NIXON DRUNK
RAMBLING, EXCEPT HE'S NOT DRUNK,
HE'S JUST RAMBLING AND IS STILL
HOLDING ON TO ALL THESE LIES.
THE EYES THAT POLL-WATCHERS WERE
BRUTALIZED BUT THERE WAS NOTHING
BUT LOVE AND THE POLICE JUST
USHERED IN THESE LOVING PEOPLE
INTO THE CAPITOL ON THE DAY OF
THE ATTACK IS SICKENING,
STUNNING, THIS IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I MEAN, I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
TO REALLY ASK ABOUT IT.
BUT WHAT WAS HE DOING DURING THE
ATTACK?
I MEAN, YOU HAVE REPORTING IN
THIS BOOK ABOUT HE WAS
UNREACHABLE.
>> ANDERSON, OUR REPORTING SHOW
THE PRESIDENT DURING THE ATTACK
WAS SITTING IN FRONT OF THE
TELEVISION WATCHING IT UNFOLD.
AT FIRST HE WAS HAPPY.
HE LIKED TO SEE HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF MAGA SUPPORTERS
WITH MAGA FLAGS STORMING THE
CAPITOL.
HE ENJOYED THAT.
HE THOUGHT HE WAS PROUD OF IT.
WHEN SHOTS WERE FIRED AND IT
BECAME DEADLY AND VIOLENT HE
BECAME MORE CONCERNED ACCORDING
TO PEOPLE AROUND HIM YET DIDN'T
ACT TO DO ANYTHING, HE WAS AWOL
AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
IT TOOK MIKE PENCE WHO'S LIFE
WAS UNDER THREAT, IN THE
BASEMENT OF THE CAPITOL TO CALL
THE PENTAGON TO ORGANIZE
MILITARY.
>> YOU ALSO HEARD THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN WAS IN THE DINING ROOM
WATCHING TELEVISION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND HE DIDN'T TAKE CALLS FROM
PEOPLE.
IVANKA TRUMP WOULD REPEATEDLY
TRY TO GET HIM TO DO SOMETHING.
>> IT WAS A REALLY AWKWARD TIME
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT REMEMBER AS
PROTESTERS LITERALLY BROKE INTO
THE LANDING NEAR THE SENATE AND
LAWMAKERS WERE SCRAMBLING FOR
THEIR LIVES ALONG WITH THEIR
STAFF WHO WERE BARRICAING AWAY
FROM PEOPLE CHANTING FOR THEIR
HEADS, DURING THAT TIME THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED SOMETHING
CRITICIZING MIKE PENCE.
EVENTUALLY THAT CAME DOWN.
IVANKA WAS ASKED BY CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS TO PLEASE,
COME DOWN HERE, LET'S GET YOUR
DAD TO SAY SOMETHING.
TO CALL OFF THE DOGS,
ESSENTIALLY.
IVANKA WENT BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN HER SECOND-FLOOR OFFICE,
BACK AND FORTH MULTIPLE TIMES AT
MEADOWS REQUEST, TRYING TO GET
IT RIGHT ESSENTIALLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT, WITH HER FATHER.
MANY PEOPLE TOLD US DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT SHE WAS DESCRIBED THAT
DAY, AND NOT EXTREMELY FORCEFUL
AT FIRST BUT SHE WAS ALSO
COMPARED TO THE STABLE PONY, TO
COME IN AND CALM THE RACE HORSE.
SHE WAS HER FATHER'S STABLE
PONY.
>> AGAIN, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
SEEN -- WE SHOWED THE VIDEO OF
THE PEACE-LOVING FOLKS FULL OF
LOVE BEING USHERED INTO THE
CAPITOL.
>> HUGGING AND KISSING.
>> RIGHT, WE HAVE THE VIDEO OF
COURSE AND WE'VE ALL SEEN WHAT
THE REALITY WAS.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT THEY WERE
FACING.
THIS IS NOT CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICERS USHERING THEM IN.
IN VIDEOS WE SEEN IT WAS HOLD
BACK THE LINE BY FALLING BACK.
THEY WERE OUTGUNNED, OUTMANNED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THE -- WERE YOU SURPRISED
HE'S STILL STICKING TO THIS?
CLEARLY THIS IS A CONVERSATION
HE HAS AROUND DINNER TABLES, ON
THE GOLF COURSE, THIS IS WHAT HE
TALKS ABOUT NONSTOP
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT JUST THIS
TOPIC WHERE HE SPEWED LIES TO US
IN OUR INTERVIEW, WE TALKED TO
HIM TWO AND HALF HOURS AND
ALMOST EVERY TOPIC IT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE REALITY PLAYING IN
HIS HEAD.
HE BROUGHT UP THE FACT ACCORDING
TO HIM HE WON THE STATE OF
ARIZONA, WE KNOW HE LOST THE
STATE OF ARIZONA BECAUSE HE WAS
ATTACKING JOHN McCAIN, I A HERO
IN THAT STATE, AND HE BROUGHT
THAT UP AND ATTACKED JOHN McCAIN
AGAIN IN OUR INTERVIEW.
IT'S JUST AGAIN AND AGAIN HE
WOULD